make sure you've got your power glove
equipped and a memory card handy we
unlocked a few long hidden secrets in
our earlier video 7 gaming Easter eggs
that weren't discovered for years well
we dug up five more gaming goodies that
remain hidden for longer than anyone
would have guessed
Mortal Kombat secret menus while feeding
The Mortal Kombat trilogy all of our
quarters during the early 90s few
suspected that the arcade versions had a
backdoor to a secret menu made by series
co-creator Ed Boon to get in you had to
hit the block button on the player 1 and
player 2 sides in a specific order then
you'd be able to run diagnostic tests
keep track of how many coins the machine
to take in and watch each character's
ending the secret menus in Mortal Kombat
3 even allowed you to unlock hidden
features watch a fatality demonstration
or play a secret delegate type game
Donkey Kong's hidden initials
an arcade legend since its debut in 1981
Donkey Kong was so popular it was ported
to the Atari 400 and 800 consoles
Landon Dyer who worked on that fork
blogged in 2008 that he hit an easter
egg in his version of the game over a
year later gamer don hodges finally
found it first
he played for the game and reached a new
high score between thirty three thousand
and thirty three thousand nine hundred
then kill off your remaining lives with
your final death by following set your
difficulty to four and after the game
loads the intro you´ll see landed dyers
initials in the title screen underneath
a Nintendo copyright after 28 years who
knew the Donkey Kong still had an
utterly useless trick up his hairy
sleeve goldeneyes in-game emulator 17
years after Goldeneye double-oh-seven s
Nintendo 64 debut one fan found
something hidden deep within its code an
in-game emulator with ten working games
the emulator includes saberwolf
attic attack jetpack lunar jet man
alienate gun fries underworld Knight
lore
and cookie all titles that goldeneyes
developer rare made the ZX Spectrum
console in the 1980s serious Sam zero
encounters there's a hidden level called
sacred yards in serious Sam the first
encounter which usually requires lots of
running and gunning years after its
release
one player found that you could skip
much of the yards by exploiting bugs and
shooting certain objects that got the
interest of youtuber celaya CEO say who
contacted the game's lead designer Roman
River ik for answers River Exede using a
level editor to unlock the game secrets
battle absol ICO say to record a perfect
playthrough 14 years after the game
launched and finally super Beanstalk
brothers after more than 30 years people
are still finding secrets for the first
Super Mario Brothers game like this one
pay attention it's kind of complicated
in a two-player game let Mario die at
world 1-2 then progress Luigi up to
world 5-2 fair proceed to the second
hammer brother there's a hidden bean
sprout on one of the blocks let Luigi
die from a hammer throw while climbing
the vine if done correctly Mario will
spawn at world 1-2 with a vine sprouting
next to him you can use the vine to keep
hitting the buzzy beetles near the start
of the level spawning 1 ups until you
reach the maximum number of extra lives
weird right
ok well not as weird as this
most know-nothing swear it's that thanks
for watching subscribe to our youtube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know which video game easter
egg is your favorite